ces personnes sont des vélos tafer
comprenait des cyclistes qui vont au
travail à vélo
beaucoup d'entre eux font la route matin
et soir jusqu'au paul 45 à ormes non
sans appréhension ça fait à peu près
plus de 20 km aller retour et il ya les
endroits qui ont des pistes cyclables et
n'a d'autres où c'est ici assez serré
c'est pas évident comment partager la
route
il ya des endroits où si je prends la
piste cyclable je mets en danger où je
mets en danger des piles et on est
parfois si je reste la route c'est moi
qui suis je pour ces cyclistes
quotidiens les aménagements cyclables
périurbain sont à revoir
entre les giratoires dangereux et les
pistes sans continuité
les vélos ne trouvent pas leur place
alors il emprunte des chemins de
substitution comme ce bout de route en
mauvais état d'une manière assez
surprenante
je vous dirais que ce trou sont là pour
un cycliste quotidien il est très bien
il est très bien par rapport à ce qu'on
voit ailleurs vous en tant que cycliste
loisirs vous trouvez que c'est quand
même assez dégradée que c'est passé par
terry moore se sent en sécurité
c'est ça vous donne un peu une idée de
tout le travail qu'il ya à faire
partout ailleurs en 2019 la métropole a
décidé de consacrer 50 3 millions
d'euros à la construction d'aménagement
cyclable un budget qui s'étalera sur dix
ans et cette politique vélo ne va pas
assez vite au goût de certains
aujourd'hui vous avez un plan vélo
national qui fixe à l'horizon 2024 9% de
déplacements à vélo au niveau national
vous n'êtes pas du tout à cette hauteur
là à orléans et dans la métropole et
en terme d'aménagement c'est demain donc
vous avez tout un ensemble de politiques
cyclables
aujourd'hui oui pour moi est insuffisant
la petite reine fait pourtant de plus en
plus d'adeptes sur l'ensemble de la
métropole
les déplacements à vélo ont bondi de 25%
en un an